تعب قانونيه فيبدو انها لا تاتي فرادا
لترامب مع عوده ملف الوثائق السريه في
فلوريدا واشنطن بوست في تقرير لها قالت
انه وزاره العدل توصلت الى ان ترامب فحص
الصناديق التي تضم مواد سريه بعد صدور امر
الاستدعاء لتسليم الوثائق فيما يبدو رغبه
في الاحتفاظ باشياء معينه بحوزته في منزله
في التفاصيل الجديده تسلط الضوء على
الدرجه التي وصل اليها تحقيق المحامي
الخاص جاك سميث في سوء التعامل المحتمل مع
مئات الوثائق السريه في منزل ترامب
التركيز الان على نقطه اعاقه سير التحقيق
واشنطن بوست سبق لها القول ان المحققين
جمعوا ادله تشير الى ان ترامب طلب من
موظفيه تضليل المسؤولين الحكوميين اوائل
العام الماضي بشان هذه الوثائق السريه
والعنصر الاساسي في معظم ق العرقله هو
النيه ويحاول المدعون العامون والوكلاء
الفيدراليون جمع اي دليل يشير الى الدافع
وراء تصرفات ترامب من بين الادله التي تم
جمعها ان ترامب تجاهل طلبات مستشاريه
لاعاده الوثائق وطلبه من محاميه اصدار
بيانات كاذبه تدعي انه اعاد جميع الوفائع
وخلاف ذلك وكما هو الحال في القضيه في
منهات فاجراءات هيئه المحلفين الكبرى سريه
ولم يقدم المحامي الخاص جاكس مث اي اشاره
علنيه الى وتيره تحقيقه او عندما يتوقع
الانتهاء منه
[موسيقى]